also  i forgot to mention this  the map comes the key  it's very small  here it is don't lose it living a little  bit  lose it  keep it safe put this key i'm gonna add  a little bit on this just  also  with this map  comes the key  very curious keep the small key keep it  with you at all times  oh i suggest a nice piece of leather  wrapped around the neck with a keyhole  right through the top  i thought make sure it's on your pretty  good yeah did i imagine don't lose it  and the map don't lose that either if  you lose the key but have the map it's  no good and if you have to keep it you  don't have the map then where are we i  can't believe you didn't get that i know  you didn't attempt to do an english  accent or nothing that was an english  accent  [Music]  you're just a deeper voice  hello i'm gandalf